quand j'étais jeune il y avait que deux
moyens de me faire lever m'arracher du
lit pour aller de force à l'école ou
aller regarder le club d roté pour voir
les chevaliers du zodiaque et Dragon
Ball Z mais ça ça sera pour plus tard
les Chevaliers du Zodiaque ça vous fait
penser à quoi les figurines hors de prix
qui valaient un mois de salaire et sans
aucun doute une de série de fou
où tout le monde se l'a péta parce que
le chevalier de son signe meulit tous
les autres en même temps lancé par
phenniix le chef des Chevaliers Noirs
dans la Vallée de la Mort la bataille
fait rage
et c'est c'est quoi toi ton personnage
préféré dans les chevaliers de zodiaque
ah ben moi c'est c'est sang Gokou ça
c'est
clair réunir la Nintendo et les
Chevaliers du Zodiaque ça partait d'un
bon sentiment mais finalement c'est un
peu comme mettre de la chantille sur de
la merde ça sera très présentable mais
je vous conseille pas d'en manger je
crois qu'il faudrait placer la
description du jeu à côté du mot
déception dans le dictionnaire allez je
vais tester cet étron pour vous
chevalier du zodiaque la légende d'or la
légende d'or mais non mais ça veut dire
quoi ça les légende d'or la légende des
chevaliers d'or bon enfin bref allonsy
la série était tellement populaire en
France que le jeu est passé de la case
Japon à la case France sans passer par
les USA en effet le jeu n'a jamais été
distribué chez l'Oncle
Sam ah d'accord mais c'est quoi C
musique là en fait je m'entendis
évidemment pas entendre Bernard Minet
chanter mais au moins le thème japonais
ou quelque chose qui ressemble enfin
bref que serait un mauvais jeu sans
mauvaise musique après tout
ok c'est quoi ce truc là qui détermine
votre signe du zodiaque peut-être ça va
être utile dans le jeu genre pour savoir
le chevalier d'or qui va avec vous et
ben pas du
tout ok alors ça c'est seard bon je me
rappelle pas qu'il avait pas de visage
hein ok donc le point c'est le B le a
c'est le saut allez let's
go euh allô c'est quoi ce truc
là non mais sérieux mais moi je voulais
jouer au chevalier du zodiaque et et pas
ça
quoi allez il faut faire
quoi dire que j'ai claqué 500 balles à
l'époque dans cette hor
merde merci l'amphilade il faudra
te souvenir de cette leçon tu dois être
toujours concentré quoi qu'il arrive le
jeu est une sorte de RPG de combat au
tour par tour où il faut sélectionner
des actions qui influeront plus ou moins
sur le combat on a une jauge de vie de
cosmos et une jauge d'XP qui serviront à
booster votre perso le reste du temps on
remplit des jauge d'attaque et de
défense pour faire des actions en dehors
de cette phase le jeu est un side
scroller où on peut rentrer dans des
bâtiments parler à des gens pour faire
avancer l'histoire ce qui peut être des
fois très ennuyeux non tout le temps
très ennuyeux en
fait surtout quand des méchants qui
ressemblent à des tas de bougiants
viennent vous
agresser mais dégage c'est quoi cette
ville sérieux mais
le jeu est vraiment très dur la
stratégie des combats m'échappe un peu
dans le sens où la meilleure méthode
c'est de remplir toutes les jauges ce
qui draine énormément votre cosmos sans
ou que vous y laissez des plumes lors
des combats vous êtes obligé de faire
des magouill exemple au colisé il est
impossible d'enchaîner tous les combats
sans perdre alors entre chaque
combattant il faut aller à l'osto pour
récupérer de l'énergie osto qui n'est
pas dans le menu d'érection et donc vous
devez y aller à pied ce qui devient
extrêmement chiant car pour y aller plus
vite il faut avoir l'armure ce qui
draine votre
cosmos petite combine dans le menu donné
on peut échanger des points de vie
contre des points de cosmos alors juste
avant de me faire soigner sachant que je
récupère mes point d'énergie je
convertis les restants en point de
cosmos n'essayez pas d'aller jusqu'à
zéro
sinon voilà regardez ça c'est s'est
suicidé super magnifique vraiment quoi
je veux dire le suicide ça me semblait
indispensable comme option les
développeurs ont vraiment passé à tout
un truc qui me rile au plus haut point
c'est qu'on doit passer le reste du
temps à naviguer dans le menu Select et
on a droit à chaque fois à quoi 9 c'est
quoi ta gueule
oh mais tu me fais peur bon là c'est le
moment où on doit récupérer les morceaux
de l'armure d'Or du Sagittaire en
affrontant les Chevaliers Noirs mont
Fuji pour une fois le décor change mais
bon quand je franchis la porte en fait
c'est le même décor avec seulement la
couleur qui
change ça me g mais ils sont où
les Chevaliers Noirs là et en plus ça se
lou plateforme là faut sauter sur de
ridicules espaces sans se varer sinon
c'est le précipice et là vous devez
remonter tout ha en subissant une
connerie de musique en boucle qui vous
agresse les oreilles et comme si ça
suffisait pas en plus vous perdez
l'énergie ah ben tiens tiens allez
crève
crève toi aussi
[Musique]
crève le problème une fois que vous avez
bouffé tout votre cosmos en plein combat
c'est que même si vous remplissez les
jaoges vous ne pouvez pas valider et là
le combat devient plutôt ridicule vous
faites fatalement allumer et alors vous
croyez que ça m'impressionne je n'ai pas
peur du tout et s'il faut mourir je
mourrai en
chevalier vous pouvez utiliser vos potes
pendant les combat mais ils sont aussi
utiles qu'un pansement sur une jambe de
bois le meilleur des persos c'est seyard
les trois autres c'est juste des
de figurants et en plus ces
puisent sur vos ressources j'espère que
tout le jeu n'est pas comme ça
[Musique]
oh mon dieu mais tout le jeu est comme
ça mais ils sont où les combats
dentesques sur de la musique épique mais
regarde ça même les traductions sont
boîteuses
[Musique]
quoi bon c'est le moment de faire ce que
chaque véritable cycliste font en
commencant leur carrière tricher
ça
va alors le mot de passe c'est dans
suite mais de merde mais c'esti
ce mot de passe à rallonge mais comment
un jeu aussi répétitif sérieux pe avoir
des mot de passes aussi gigantesques le
passe c'est tu as gagné tu es passé
maîre moi j'aurais mis tu es dégoûté tu
vas finir cette
merde ah maintenant j'ai tout à fond je
vais balayer tout le monde d'un coup je
vais devenir le maître des chevaliers je
vais finir le jeu en 2 de en 22 en 2 de
en 2 de en de de
mais mais qu'est-ce qu'il
m'arrive ma vision se
trouble je ne peux pas
abandonner je perds mes
sens mon cosmos fa
[Musique]
oui ton cosmos tu dois l'allumer pour
qu'il brûle et explose et chacun de tes
coup changera en météore
[Applaudissements]
rassemble tes dernières
forces je t'ai paralysé tous les Ners de
la tête jusqu'au
[Musique]
pieds mais qu'est-ce que tu
fais tu crois donc que tu peut me
vaincre pauvre idiot
[Musique]
am